fundamentally I think my journey of
becoming hopefully more holy human is
bringing on lines sensitivities that I
took offline as a kid if you've shut off
certain types of feeling which I had
done when you feel any inkling of
certain emotions you then have a harsh
inner critic to shut those things down I
think for someone like me who's
comfortable operating in spreadsheets
and dividing and conquering
deconstructing like you said it's like
okay well let's separate these things
out so it's not one big amorphous
problem here are these 17 different
problems and then how am I going to
address the first but let me rank order
these and figure out which are the most
negative in terms of amplitude of impact
in my life okay
that's one approach but if those are
symptoms that are presenting from a
problem that is underlying all of those
things you're just gonna be playing
whack-a-mole it's not going to be
Curative in any way